all right Kim we have two hundred and
sixteen years of Democratic Party
history to cover let's cut the
pleasantries and get right to it who is
this man that is Thomas Jefferson he
does not look like the baby-faced boy
that he was in this image is this his
presidential portrait I believe so yes
so Thomas Jefferson I think is really
interesting because he didn't set out to
found a party right although he ended up
doing so it was more that he had a
competing vision about what the United
States should be that was different from
the vision that was being promoted by
some of the men who were in power early
in the nation's history like like
Washington Adams Alexander Hamilton what
what is the difference between Jefferson
and Hamilton's views on governance and
how did this become the Democratic Party
Hamilton had an idea that he was going
to try to make the government a little
bit more centrist so a strong central
government remember they've just
switched to the Constitution from the
Articles of Confederation what are you
worth uh 1787 and Hamilton thinks that
there needs to be a strong central
government a National Bank a kind of
limited democracy right a democracy that
is limited to more educated landed men
and he wants the United States to be a
lot like England and Jefferson and
people who felt like Jefferson like
James Madison we're saying whoa whoa
whoa this is not what we rebelled
against England for to become England
part two instead what we should have is
very expanded democracy democracy for
lots of people doesn't matter you know
their birth and much more agrarian state
focused small government okay and this
is what we still called the Jeffersonian
ideal exactly yeah small our republic
right citizens who are mainly farmers
now of course the expanded democracy
that Jefferson's thinking about doesn't
apply to women or african-americans
Jefferson himself was a slave holder but
he didn't want to limit governance to
only the elite so
so the Jeffersonian ideal is a republic
for all landholding citizens exactly but
in 1800 the idea of what citizen meant
was very limited in blinkered so this
doesn't really take root until the
emergence of Andrew Jackson and late
1820s he finally gets elected in 1832 so
Jackson really pushes the idea of
democracy for all white men to its
farthest conclusion which means that in
this time period he expanded the
franchise to any white man regardless of
his property which means that this is
the most democracy in the history of the
world up until this point yeah but let
me point out that you did say all white
men exactly so Jackson is unabashedly a
racist and his vision of manifest
destiny really involves the eradication
of all Native Americans I mean this is a
really dark time for American Indian
policy this is when we see something
called the Indian Removal Act that is
literally what it's called Jackson's
presidency is also marked by the
Cherokee diaspora the the forced removal
of the Cherokee of on what's called the
Trail of Tears yep so so okay so before
Jackson do we really have the Democratic
Party as an institution no before this
we would have called this the
anti-federalists or the
democratic-republicans so Hamilton
it's a Federalist position Jefferson is
an anti federalists right so okay so so
we have we have these kicking around but
they wouldn't they're not parties in the
same way that we would see them now
there's sort of policy positions yeah I
would say so having like a mass
political party was really an invention
of the Jackson era so one did not run
for president in the 18 early 1800s one
stood for president as gentlemen around
you talked of your virtues right it
wasn't a campaign oh so you couldn't
actually campaign for yourself right
that was that was very uncouth I see so
Jackson is is the real antidote to this
he creates
massive democracy the turnout in this
time period is like 8090 percent right
so everybody goes to vote okay so let's
talk about this some this political
cartoon well it's really just making fun
of Andrew Jackson for being incredibly
stubborn he vetoed everything because
the position of the Democratic Party
which is is founded with Jackson he
vetoes everything because he believes in
small government so he thinks that the
power of the government should be
negative right the less federal power
the better which is interesting for a
president right so it's in this time
period from probably this cartoon that
we get the image of the donkey as the
icon of the Democratic Party because
Jack's son many believed was a jackass
so the Democratic Party as a party of
all white men ends up having a difficult
relationship with slavery right which is
the major issue of 19th century America
and the issue of slavery really ends up
kind of breaking the Democratic Party
apart because in the election of 1860
they actually split into the northern
Democrats and the Southern Democrats and
run two different candidates for
president whoa why I knew that the Whigs
were split on slavery what split the
Democrats slavery again so the southern
democrats really supported the expansion
of slavery everywhere the northern
democrats were just trying to prevent
the Union from breaking up so they were
still pro-slavery but pro-union yes and
that's why they only carried Missouri is
that when it says Douglass here's that
Stephen Douglas that is Stephen Douglas
famous foe of Abraham Lincoln and
Stephen Douglas actually died I think in
1861 which was a real shock for the
Democratic Party because they lost the
real major leader in the north and so
they are the minority party as Abraham
Lincoln and the first Republican leads
the United States to victory in the
Civil War and so having been kind of the
opposition party against the victorious
party in war means that the Democrats
are in a fairly bad political position
really for most of the rest of the 19th
century right because this is the the
real ascension era of the Republicans as
they wave the bloody shirt so the
Republican Party bled to save the Union
exactly okay that's your bloody shirt
that's my blue shirt it's amazing it's
there it is little motion blur for you
waving it okay I gotcha so okay so so
this this rhetorical strategy of saying
hey remember the Republicans were the
ones that saved the Union that basically
makes the Democrats of a rump party
right yeah the rest of the $0.19 they're
in bad shape but they do have a few
moments especially in the late 19th
century there's a major economic
depression and remember economic
depression is never good for the party
that's in power right so in the panic of
1893
there's just major economic trouble and
in this time period it's an important
moment for the Democratic Party
all right so Kim who's this fella so
this is William Jennings Bryan and uh
he's one of those guys who ran for
president so many times but never
actually won so we don't cross a gold
speak exactly right so he had this idea
that the United States should move off
the gold standard and instead allow
silver as one of the currencies backing
the US dollar and this what the idea
behind this was that then the money
would flow flood into the economy and
people would get wealthier and it would
end this depression and that's not how
it happened but it does do is is moves
the Democratic Party in a more populist
direction taking care of the smaller
people who need more help financially
right so a more interventionist economic
policy and so they want to kind of start
helping the little guy with money and
you see this kind of in would call the
progressive era which Wilson who's going
to be the next Democratic president
starting in 1912 he's a big champion of
progressivism and it's under Wilson's
rule that the 19th amendment granting
women the right to vote is passed
so this is kind of anti-corruption
anti-monopoly very Pro trying to protect
the consumer so this is where the sort
of more liberal aspect of democratic
monetary policy comes from I don't want
to give the impression that
progressivism and Wilson were 100% good
things on one hand Wilson was the first
southern president he was a Virginian
since the Civil War after this era of
waving the bloody shirt and one of the
things that Wilson does is he segregates
federal jobs so many african-americans
who were working in the federal
government were forced out under Wilson
and don't forget that Wilson is the
president who screened the Pro KKK film
Birth of a Nation at the White House in
1915 yeah all right and then what
happened and then the stock market crash
happened yeah and the stock market crash
happened under Republican rule and it's
never a good thing when your party's in
power and there's a major economic
downturn right and that's during the
Hoover administration exactly before
then and so it's after this economic
crash that Franklin Delano Roosevelt
comes into power and now Roosevelt has
this very liberal approach to economics
right and this is where sort of
contemporary modern American liberalism
comes from which is an idea that
government should regulate the economy
you know they shouldn't control the
economy but they should try to mediate
some of these major swings that the
economy could make and also that
government has a responsibility for the
welfare of its people so FDR implements
the New Deal which is a really sweeping
set of social programs designed to try
to get people out of their depression
and guarantee a certain standard of
living for all Americans some of those
programs from the New Deal that we still
have today Social Security I think would
be one of the biggest ones it's you know
a living wage for the elderly or the
disabled and the FDIC the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation which
backs banks for example but what's
interesting about this is that we often
think
the Democratic Party and the Republican
Party kind of having opposite stances on
things but the Democratic Party in this
time period kind of had a liberal
northern weighing and then a southern
conservative wing so there are two kind
of parts of the Democratic Party so
let's look at this map here what is this
solid South so this is the solid south
and the solid south is the Democratic
Pro Jim Crow South so there's the
Democratic Party in the south which is
much smaller government really wanted to
make sure that african-americans were
prevented from having political power in
the south so it's interesting because
african-americans after FDR really
joined the Democratic Party but in the
south most of them can't vote right so
very uncomfortable alliance so Kim sorry
I thought that I thought that this part
of the country the Northeast was still
pretty solidly Republican at this time I
would say that FDR puts together kind of
a New Deal coalition of labor unions
ethnic and religious minorities sort of
the the workers of the United States who
want a more interventionist government
economy but don't necessarily want the
the moralizing aspect that goes along
with say like the Progressive Era right
these the the progressives passed
prohibition for example right they
thought it was morally bad to drink and
one of the first thing FDR does when he
gets into office is to repeal
prohibition saying you know what America
needs now is a drink right so it doesn't
have this moral aspect but it does have
economic control okay but the party
continues to kind of move to the left on
social issues and in the mid-1960s
Lyndon Johnson starts to pass civil
rights legislation like the Civil Rights
Act of 1964 and also pretty sweeping
social programs would you call like this
the Great Society so this is things like
head starts and lots of welfare programs
and in this time period along with the
civil rights movement you know the
Democratic Party really coalesce is
around this group in in the north who
are more Pro civil rights so this period
from FDR's election through Lyndon
Johnson's administration is really kind
of the Democratic heyday in the United
States save for eisenhower there is no
other Republican president that's
elected during this time period so this
is 30-plus years of democratic
ascendancy but it kind of comes apart in
1968 so what happens in 1968 well
there's a lot of social unrest the
assassination of Martin Luther King jr.
the assassination of Robert F Kennedy
many summer riots and many whites in the
South who had you know followed this
Democratic coalition here began to feel
that civil rights movement and the
commitment of the Democratic Party to
civil rights had gone too far
basically and there was the problem of
Vietnam the Vietnam War which both
parties were really strongly
anti-communist in this time period so
many of the sort of young people who
might otherwise have supported the
Democratic Party began to feel that the
Democratic Party too was part of this
war machine that was just sending the
United States citizens to fight a war
that they believe they had nothing to do
with so we're seeing this demographic
shift exactly so this solid South which
had been voting Democratic because they
had really complete political hegemony
right because african-americans couldn't
vote now that african-americans can vote
many of those whites end up switching to
the Republican Party interesting all
right so Johnson decides he's not even
going to run again right because he
knows he can't win because the Vietnam
war has just tarnished him in the sight
of most Americans so with the Democrats
really split apart in complete disarray
the Republicans take back the White
House so okay so Kim that takes us up to
about 1968 and the election of Nixon and
there's a lot of history of the
Democratic Party two hundred and sixteen
years right yep is
it is the oldest voter based political
party in the world so we can't fit the
entire history into one video no there's
too much so next time when we come back
we're going to talk about the New
Democrats under President Clinton we're
going to talk about the Obama
administration and the policy and the
plank of the Democratic Party going
forward so stay tuned